let's assume there's a heart and soul
for every screenplay
and if that's the case how does the
director find that the heart and soul of
the screenplay
I would say yeah there is a heart and
soul for the story and hopefully it's in
the screenplay the in the rib there's a
reason I make that distinction is
because many times it's a very strong
story in the screenplay which is
screenplay which is basically a step in
a process of bringing it to a film the
screenplay hasn't really captured that
so listen
but the story there's a heart and the
soul in this story and that I think in
discussion with the writer or writers
whoever they are that's the first thing
you've got to find and it's like Elsa
and I had a consultation just yesterday
on a script and with the writers and
what we were looking for it's just what
you're talking about that what's the
heart and soul of this it's a really
interesting screenplay it's a thriller
action invention thriller but what is at
the heart so loved it that the audience
can grab on to and identify with my
feeling is the audience doesn't really
want to watch a big action-adventure
film what they want I mean they'll watch
it be thrilled to watch it one that's
well done but they want to connect with
the people and what the people's journey
is and what the people's struggles are
and what the people's epiphanies are or
disappointments are in the
transformation of characters that's what
they want to they want to connect with
the aspect of that story that relates to
their own lives which may be very subtle
or may very very powerful but we have to
identify that so talking with these
these two writers yesterday that was the
goal is to find that and then once we
can identify that with the writers then
we could eat all of us can I ask you
something is it in the script is it
clear in the script that that's what it
is but first of all you got to feel what
it is and that's why many times looking
at a script you can feel it's not there
but rather than trying to cover it up
or pretend it's there or soon and it's
there or just insert something there go
back to the writers go back to the
people who had the original idea and
find out what that is and then try to
identify that and that is actually for a
director that's what's gonna guide you
through the entire rest of the process
that's what the movie is all about then
some movie is all about this character
who is fighting these struggles were
fighting these aspects of himself and
the world around him and his family or
his work or whatever he's fighting and
that what gets revealed through that
process is what this man or this woman
is going through that we can identify
with it so you got to get that early
then the process of the rewrites
re-examining script is how can we get
that in how can we make that clear to
the audience also clear to the actors
really important so the actors can see
it the actors who are playing these
parts can attach themselves to that so
if it's not clear is it because we're
not having an emotional response to it
or we're not having the emotional
response that the writer intended us to
have are probably both we're not have an
emotional response or the one that's
intended or the one that's assumed by
the writer okay this is this is a danger
of writing this is getting back to that
assumption thing we're talking about
before which we deal a lot with I'm
gonna go back to write your life I'm
telling you a story about a traumatic
experience I had that's for instance a
personal experience and I'm going to
assume that if I tell you everything
that happened you're going to have the
same emotional reaction I did that's a
huge assumption you may not a writer can
write a script and may be true may be
personal may be totally fiction but the
writer right in that script and all
those characters is having an emotional
experience as he or she is creating it
with these characters how they're
relating to each other all the twists
and turns in the story and they're going
oh that's great that's great assuming
that anybody else reading it will be
having the same reaction that may not be
true so that the
assumption of the writer is a problem
can be a problem and the best way to
deal with that is really simple you tell
the writer there's your problem
you wrote that scene and you're very
moved by it I read the scene I don't get
it okay what you're intending is great
I'm not getting it and other people are
not you're assuming they were getting it
because you are so identified with those
characters in that situation okay not a
problem let's figure out how we can make
it clearer to the artist so the audience
does get it and that's my job as a
director that's my job as a directing
consultant or a writing consultant is to
help writers get to that point where the
scene is clear and note one thing which
we don't need to talk a lot about but
one thing is a script
speaking of scripts and writer a script
initially in order to get made into a
movie has to engage the reader and as
you know the reader very often is not
the person who's going to produce it the
reader is somebody down the line and
some production company whatever it does
you in other words that script by itself
by its little self those 120 pages has
to impact that reader so the first thing
is let's make sure the reader gets at
the reader who just picks up another
script and starts reading gets it that's
really crucial
so forget me the director and forget all
the other people we got it we got to
make sure that the script is strong
enough that that works and if it's not
doing it then it's not going to get made
and the writer can deal with his for his
or her frustration like why can't they
get it don't go there don't go why can't
they get it let's go back to how good
this is what a lot of people like
Michael Haig and Chris Vogel and all
those people teach screenwriting work
with writers on it's not lots of times
it's not about what the story is is
about how do you craft these scenes and
characters and it's a certain way that
the writer will get it and eventually
all the other people who are going to
work on it so then the writer needs to
know their assumptions and their lenses
that they see the world through as well
yes
yes exactly that's why a lot of writers
take write your life just start to see
the you're right that those lenses as
you toggle those filters that you're
looking and the assumption is a filter
and looking through that well you know I
I had this I'm just gonna make this up I
had this about with cancer and I fought
off cancer and I took you know
robbed me of a year of my life but now
I'm a cancer survivor and I could tell
you about it and you should feel
horrified by what happened because I did
and frightened and someone could tell me
that I go OK it's not it's not gonna
impact me the way you think it is only
because you as you tell it
we re experienced everything you went
through so that filter of assumption
that filter of assumption of a writer
even writing fiction I created this
great moment in the scene and nobody
gets it well then we have to keep
working on it I understand what you're
going for I understand what you want
them to get you haven't crafted it in a
way for them to get it so it's also
understanding not only from a writer's
point of view not only on standing there
layer or barrier of assumption and
because every screen right I think this
is really true finishes the screenplay
thinks it's brilliant hopefully they do
why otherwise why do it and that's an
assumption too but also they have to
realize that every reader has barriers
against certain things that you have to
plow through you have to break through
you have to surprise them you have to
sort of find your way around the
barriers and the obstacles that the
reader has within themselves so yes you
have to understand yourself and you have
to understand you can't say why don't
you get that you have to understand they
they don't get it for a reason
you